if you teach people to broaden their
focus
to begin to instead of focusing on
everything material and physical that's
causing the stress everything that's
known
broaden their focus and put their
attention on space on nothing
and the act of doing that
causes the brain to begin to synchronize
to begin to unify to become more
coherent
and what sinks in the brain links in the
brain so the person's brain
starts functioning normally and starts
to improve without any medications
without any therapies just a simple act
and the more they do it
the more order that creates that's
created in their brain the more they can
focus their attention and move into a
more creative state what do i want how
do how successful do i want to be how
healthy do i want to be how much love do
i want in my life you can ask the bigger
questions by the same means
when the person is gripped by those
hormones of stress and they're not
running from predator they're not
fighting
and they're not freezing and hiding but
the chemicals are running their heart is
beating
because it's in an aroused state but
it's beating against the closed system
and the heart starts beating
incoherently when that happens energy
leaves the heart and we stop trusting we
stop believing in ourselves so
we teach people how to create brain and
heart coherence
and what we discovered just in the last
couple years
is that when this heart starts beating
orderly and it's a skill just like
anything else you do like dancing the
sounds like you when you understand all
that information and now you're in the
application of it
once you start to experience it and you
get the feeling of what it feels like to
be in the state
it turns out
that when the heart is coherent it
starts informing the brain you'll see it
the brain starting to change because the
heart is telling the brain
it's time to create
now it's safe to create it's the
creative center
so the person all of a sudden can see a
possibility that they never could see
before
and they can embrace the emotion
of the event listen closely
before the experience happens now this
is fundamentally important because most
people are waiting for their wealth to
feel abundant and worthy they're waiting
for their success to feel empowerment
they're waiting for the new relationship
to feel loved they're waiting for their
healing to feel gratitude
that's cause and effect that's waiting
for something outside to change to take
away this feeling of emptiness or lack
or pain or guilt or whatever
we found out that when a person can
actually embrace the emotion
before the event
they can begin to condition their brain
and body
into a future experience and the brain
and body don't know the difference so
all of a sudden the person who was
traumatized
and had their had their experience
now all of a sudden they're teaching
their body emotionally how to live in a
new environment and the body doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience and the one that they're
fabricating so in a sense
there by creating brain and heart
coherence
the stronger the emotion they feel for
their new vision of their future
the more they're going to pay attention
to the picture in their mind and they're
literally remembering their future
and now there's biological changes in
gene expression in neurological
circuitry in brain coherence and immune
regulation in digestive balance in by
microbiomes and all the things we
measure show the body's now out of
survival
it's time for growth and repair so the
side effect of that is we see people
with
those serious health conditions that
were actually initiated because of the
trauma
all of a sudden when they feel that
elevated emotion it's like they've taken
their body out of the past
into the present moment and now the body
all of a sudden
recalibrates and if the quotient of
their excitement for their new life for
their new future the emotional quotient
of their dream
is greater than the betrayal or the
shock
or the trauma
there's immediate reorganization in the
brain
and
an immediate change emotionally in the
body and now the person looks back at
their past and we've interviewed enough
people
to know this is the truth and they say
i don't want to change anything in my
past
i
all of that
brought me to this moment
and that's the moment the past no longer
exists so people can have a brutal past
where we've had people that have had
abuse physical sexual um emotional
that have gone through all kinds of uh
abuse
were suicidal had all kinds of health
conditions and in one instant
in one instant one inner experience from
the meditative process
begins to
change everything
about the way they see their past
they're seeing it from a greater level
of consciousness they're seeing it from
a place of love they're seeing that all
of that had to happen
it makes sense to get to this point and
now they're no longer victimized by
their disease they're no longer
victimized by their past in fact they
they'll tell you my that had to happen
for me to have my healing now
they're in a new state of being the the
disease the trauma exists in somebody
else
they've just become somebody different
and so the uh the side effect of that is
we've seen blind people see we've seen
deaf people here we've seen people in
wheelchairs that have been paralyzed
from strokes step out of wheelchairs
we've seen people with all kinds of rare
genetic disorders that science had no
solution for there it is
and then it's gone wanna be happy build
a life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
more inside you you've got michael
jordan level genius at something so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how we can become supernatural
with dr joe dispenza
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two carry positive energy i
always say to people
when was the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and afraid and
protected
it takes practice to to do that and and
so we we work with people in letting
them
we give them numerous opportunities
to practice this over and over and over
again and sooner or later pedal by pedal
it starts to bloom and all of a sudden
there's an authentic smile on their face
and once energy meets the heart
it goes right to the brain we have we
did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain
but we measure the heart along with it
and when the heart starts beating
coherently
in a sense of order
like like taking a big sheet jay and
going like that
the heart sends a wave right up to the
brain
and the brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and there's the stroke volume of the
heart in order and then you see these
two or three seconds of beautiful
coherent alpha the brain is in it's it's
in that creative state then there's a
pause and it happens again and yeah it's
it's it's beauty it's a it's a symphony
if you don't have that mechanism you can
have all the intention in the world but
there's no carrier wave i mean
when people when they make energy uh
reach their heart there's an external
field that's created it's it's it's
magnetic it's it's it's measurable
and that energy
is frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering
cannot carry the thought of health or
wealth it's not consistent with it it
carries a different set of thoughts
so then
the training then
is getting people into those hard states
because
once they start trading
that fear or that pain or that
frustration or trying or whatever
forcing you know control
for gratitude and they just let all that
go and i say to them listen
if you can't feel gratitude if you can't
feel love i just want to know what
you've been practicing feeling every day
because that feeling that you're
practicing is what you're always feeling
now let's practice feeling something
else in the beginning it's not going to
be easy but you got to keep following
the formula keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it
well
when i start feeling gratitude it's very
interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you
something favorable is happening to you
right so
you've just received something or you're
receiving something you say thank you so
gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different destiny
you could say i'm healthy i'm healthy
i'm healthy i'm wealthy and wealthy and
wealthy and wealthy and free and free
i'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying no you're not
and that thought stops right at the
brain stem
it never makes it to the body because
the body is on a different program
so then
while the person starts trading that and
they start opening their heart well
their immune system gets stronger by
fifty percent fifty percent in three
days they start making immunoglobulins
their body's natural defense against
viruses and bacteria fifty percent not a
little bit a lot that's that's one study
and so
trading that
telling the body it's in the in the
environment where it already happened
and so that's when the miracles start
happening that's when people say
i'm not doing anything well of course
you're not
you don't have to rule number three get
beyond yourself we had bond university
uh a university in australia on the gold
coast
a senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team
was our community's ability
to go to
to get to that point where they're
nobody no one no thing nowhere in no
time i'm talking four seconds
i'm talking five seconds i'm talking
nine seconds just like just give me a
second i know how to do this they
they've practiced it enough times that
the creative moment is when you get
beyond yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your material world
turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into alpha
and theta
you're suppressing the memory bank of
the known self that keeps you plugged
into three-dimensional reality when you
quiet down this mechanism
now
all of a sudden you start connecting to
that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four be present if you
take a person and you have them
uh close their eyes
and mentally rehearse doing bicep curls
in their mind and they come for one hour
a day into a clinic
and you add the emotional component
of stronger
harder
more intense
and they practice that close with their
eyes closed never lifting away
at the end of two weeks
their muscle strength increases by 13.5
percent now what so wait one hour one
hour a day though visualizing it for an
hour a day doing bicep curls okay
so that means then
when we're truly present
and we add an emotional component
if you can do it in the present moment
and stay present and repeat it
over and over again
when the brain is in the present moment
it will not know the difference between
the real life event of contracting your
muscles and doing it in your mind and
your brain will begin to look like
you've been doing it all along and you
begin to activate new circuits in your
brain
and if you repeat it you fire and wire
it more circuits begins to create a
neurological network a new level of mind
so research shows then
that people who never played the piano
before you can divide them into two
categories
and you can do a brain scan on one group
of people
and then set them in front of a piano
and teach them one-handed scales and
chords and they come for two hours a day
and they practice those scales and
chords for five days
at the end of five days they rescan
their brain and lo and behold they grow
new circuits on the opposite side of the
brain no magic there you learn something
new learning is making new synaptic
connections you get some instruction you
gotta get your body involved you get
your body involved you're going to have
a new experience experience enriches the
brain
pay attention to what you're doing you
got to pay attention and stay present
and repeat it over and over again firing
and wiring you're going to assemble new
neural architecture you can take another
group of people have them close their
eyes
and mentally rehearse
playing those scales and chords for two
hours a day for five days scan their
brain before and scan their brain after
at the end of five days they grow the
same amount of circuits in their brain
as the people who were physically doing
it now
what that means is if you take those
people and you set them in front of the
piano without ever lifting a finger
they can play those scales and chords
why because they prime their brain for a
future behavior
so if you truly wanted to change some
aspect of yourself
then you would have to ask yourself
who do i want to be when i open my eyes
now right the act of answering that
question is going to turn on your
frontal lobe and the frontal lobe
has connections to all other parts of
the brain
and it's interested in answering that
question because it is the creative
center
so as it begins to scan the landscape of
the brain it can only gather information
from things you've intellectually
learned or things you've experienced in
your life and it begins to associate
those different memories with the
question and when you get enough
networks of neurons firing in your brain
you see an image or a picture
that's intention and then as you begin
to live and rehearse who you're going to
be
you begin to do that exact same thing
you begin to install neurological
hardware in your brain
repeat it it becomes a software program
and you begin to behave that way now the
brain is primed it's no longer a record
of the past it's a map to the future now
the person
can feel the emotions of their future
you're going to see a person
move into a different state of being and
they're going to have all kinds of
biological changes and that begins to
change their biology every single day
some people do it faster some people do
it slower rule number five connect to
divinity when you hit pay dirt like that
when you connect when you connect to the
field when you connect the divine
whatever you want to call it when your
consciousness merges with a greater
consciousness and that arousal creates
ecstasy bliss oneness whatever you want
to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the wardrobe or the facelift the sports
car whatever it came from within you and
so you stop looking out there for it and
now the love affair begins and you never
want to miss a date because it's just
too good
so that memory then
that is what i'm after because when you
have those transcendental moments and
you understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment
lays down new circuitry in the brain
that's what experience does
and the experience produces a feeling
but it's not chemical it's electric and
it's orderly and every cell of your body
is
jiggling in an order and there and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs
your spectrum of reality is going to
broaden some conditioning some illusion
something is removed and you start
seeing reality as it is and all of a
sudden you start seeing the part that we
edit out for survival
now you start seeing patterns and lights
and information
that are transcendent of
three-dimensional reality and your
spectrum why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry is there
and now your your experience of the
world changes you get an upgrade to the
to the vr set
the virtual reality said oh you got the
upgrade you got 2.0 and now it looks
different everything looks different
everybody looks different
the world look you're seeing beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together
i mean that's the blessing of an
awakening right that's where that's
where we're going rule number six
strengthen your inner world if something
outside of you is controlling your
feelings and thoughts then it makes you
a victim to your environment so then yes
so you will be
more victimized or more
you could be more of a victim to other
things in your environment people don't
understand this consciously because it's
a program subconsciously
so
so now
if you begin to strengthen your inner
environment now this is where our work
comes in because we have research to
show
that when you place your attention right
here in your heart this center right
here this is this is the beginning of
our divinity this is our center of
oneness our wholeness this is where we
begin to feel love gratitude compassion
kindness care freedom joy
it's all these elevated emotions that
are heartfelt emotions that our research
shows
that when you begin to teach people how
to open this center
and you teach them a formula on how to
practice it
that if they did that for
four days
that
they would begin to strengthen their
immune system by 50
and now let me tell you why because in
the center
is your heart but what most people don't
know there's another gland in there
called the thymus gland
fine leaf it's named after the the the
time leaf and the thymus gland has two
functions it has an endocrinological
function it makes growth hormone that's
our youth center
and it makes
uh strong immune chemicals and it has an
immunological function so when you're
living by stress and your heart is
racing and you're stepping on the gas
and the brake at the same time because
you can't run you can't fight you can't
hide
and you've got the gas in the clutch
cone energy is going to leave the
harness going to the adrenal center and
you're going to cause contraction in the
arteries in your heart and this center
will shut down from blood flow
and so
there's no energy in the heart so you
teach a person then how to begin to open
the center and to start feeling elevated
emotions through their heart
and you teach them how to switch or
convert from the sympathetic nervous
system to the parasympathetic nervous
system well all of a sudden now this
thymus gland which normally shrinks
with age starting at puberty
the fountain of youth now
all of a sudden begins to get new blood
flow
and there's new hormones that are
signaled like oxytocin
and vasopressin
and all these different chemicals called
nitric oxide and endothelial derived
relaxing factor and the arteries in the
heart begin to swell with energy and
blood flow and this center switches on
and now it says man this feels good and
this is a time for us to really get back
into balance
and really let's strengthen our inner
world
and now all of a sudden
this thymus gland begins to make
thymusin which is an important agent
that begins to make t cells
and t cells have little receptors on
them called t cell receptors
and when those t cell receptors are
robust and strong
those cells
make proteins and they make what's
called antibodies or immune
immunoglobulins
and these little y-shaped proteins block
the receptors coming from the virus that
are trying to attack the white blood
cells they have a shield and now they're
they're immune
to the to the virus
and its attack with its receptor
and it can literally begin to inject it
with these immunoglobulins primary
immunoglobulin a
and that begins to cause the virus to
not survive wow then that white blood
cell will cut
pass another white blood cell and pass
on the memory to it so it already knows
what's coming so now
all of a sudden you're making these
immunoglobulins and now your inner world
now can combat anything that's that's a
foreign agent and even cancer
rule number seven tap into constructive
energy i think that if we share the same
experiences because we like the same
things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information yeah and if we share the
same energy energy is information so
many people as an example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you then you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're
someone who's has a uh accountability
partner that that you exchange ideas
like this with and it's a different
frequency and different energy so
when energy comes together it's
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance then
your your sensing meter is how you feel
about that person many times in your gut
or in your heart or wherever and there's
decons there's a
destructive interference and there's no
energy involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition then that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model
that we use so imagine 1500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes and we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our truth meter
is really whether we feel it lifted
uh or we feel like we've been robbed and
rule number eight the last one before
some very special bonus clips is elevate
yourself
how
bad
does it have to get i mean to what
denominator
to what lowest level do you have to
reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait i mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not answering your cell phone you're not
responding to all your texts you're not
watching tv you're not going out to
dinners you're not calling people back
you're something's altered in you and
you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then
people wait to that lowest moment where
they can start to see themselves through
the eyes of somebody else well if you're
waking up every day and you're combining
a clear intention with an elevated
emotion and you're changing your
emotional state to be
elevated
you could still see the old self from an
elevated point of view and be state
conscious then from a limited point of
view and that's what i want for people
like let's go i mean what do you got to
lose what people are going to start
wondering like did you change your
medication yeah what's up with that guy
something's different about him you're
not predictable any longer right now we
say to our
our community you know when you're
changing you just stop talking about it
you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row
of that really well i always say
god if you had a great meditation you
wake up feeling better at the end of
that meditation than when you started
and you do that the next day and then
the next day you're going to start
feeling better all the time and that
your body is going to start feeling
better and everything is going to start
feeling better and you're going to start
feeling better about life
if we teach a person then how to trade
that frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a cannon and shoot them to the
moon now what are you going to do sooner
or later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude as an example yes the
person says well i can't feel gratitude
and i say absolutely you can because you
don't practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny you've got to maintain
that modified state of mind and body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready
because something weird or unusual some
synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well i was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think
you're back to the unconscious program
that you're the victim to your life you
got it but when you start producing
those outcomes in your life you're going
to pay attention to what you did inside
of you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life three
types of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress trauma
accidents injuries false
chemical stress toxins pollutants heavy
metals blood sugar levels viruses
bacterias mold and then there's
emotional stress which has everything to
do with raising kids and
and second mortgages and single
parenting and time and
and all of those different elements
knock the brain and body out of balance
and the emotional component has always
been the challenging one for most people
because you could be in a constant state
of fear if you're sitting down and you
start thinking about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event your body doesn't know the
difference between the event that's
taking place in your world our world and
what you're creating by emotion or
thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden
once they step into that unknown they'd
rather feel guilt in suffering because
at least they can predict it being the
unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day the act of
rehearsing them mentally closing your
eyes and rehearsing the action
the rehearsing the reaction of what you
want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world so then you
begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like the
event that's already occurred now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
now it's a map to the future and if you
keep doing it priming it that way
the hardware becomes a software program
and who knows you just may start acting
like a happy person the stronger the
emotion you feel from some event in your
life be it a betrayal or a trauma or
whatever yes the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you pay attention
to the cause outside of you so the brain
takes a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true i just want
to understand the maybe the larger the
event in terms of its emotion to you the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology
so some certain people have a strong
experience in their life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on for
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so that now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right wow
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back i think
this is a time in history where it's not
enough to know this is a time in history
to know how
and if you rewind the tape 10 years ago
you know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in 10 years ago
when i went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself yeah you're
going to get uncomfortable right
and um
i think we're in an age of information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of technology we
have access to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change i think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
education model journalism uh
the economy you know uh politics it's
all beginning to uh
come to the surface because something
else has to come out and and i think
that one of the things that people are
realizing is that you don't have to be a
buddhist monk to do this or a nun with
40 years of devotion you just got to
understand the formula and just like any
skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it crossing that
river of change from the old self to the
new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or
you can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest
scans are people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible
and they go all in not fifty percent in
not sixty percent and we do a week-long
event we got a thousand people or
fifteen hundred people and they are all
in and that when they start getting
beyond themselves that first day or
second day once they start getting
beyond themselves
and that magic starts to happen then i
have no idea i can't predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty pretty exciting would you
speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
[Music]
think about
frozen circuits
frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted
everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting
and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are
blessing those centers and taking a
scoop and moving it all the way up and
releasing it all the way up into the
field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy's
gonna move it's got to it's going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a quantum perspective you
are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage
because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone
it's because there's been a strong
change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start
lowering the volume to that emotion and
the body starts liberating energy and
you're calling your energy back to you
because the lower the volume of the
emotion the less you're going to pay
attention to that person there comes a
moment where there's a snap
there's a release the energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life
the people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and i let them
go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for the
grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still
now once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you think
why would i want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness
you don't have to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites
as fear and it lowers the volume to fear
and anxiety it shuts the lights out for
aggression and anger and hostility and
it cools the circuits off for suffering
and pain and the only thing you can feel
is a love for life
and that's when you're free now the
practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him yeah
[Music]
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe
severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
in the
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said
and she was an incredible bliss when
this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was she was
isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that
moment is what she was waiting for
that's what the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life reborn
in the same life didn't pass through a
birth canal for it
she just was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried with
made total sense to her
she's free one instant
to me that's true forgiveness think of
your autonomic nervous system
as the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that autonomic is
synonymous with automatic and it's that
part of our systems a part of our
nervous system that functions behind the
scenes of our awareness and it regulates
body temperature and and hormones and
blood supply and blood sugar levels uh
in it and it happens without any uh uh
of our conscious mind
so in the autonomic nervous system there
are two branches so one is the
sympathetic nervous system
and its job is for protection
from threats and dangers in our outer
environment and think of the sympathetic
nervous system as the gas pedal and when
there's a danger to the gross anatomy of
the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses
this system is switched on automatically
and once it turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions
that begin to happen automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources uh for that
threat or that danger to deal with it
and and when it's switched on
uh we don't go half in we go all the way
in because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones
we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off respiratory rate increases heart
rate increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized the immune system dials up
and then it dials down and all of these
systems switching on and turning on is
to be able to allow the body to adapt to
some threat in the outer world and
uh that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run
from the danger
to fight
and stay or to freeze and hide
and those are the primary choices that
we have created in evolution
and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on
and we as we've been saying for very
long for a very long time
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and think of that nervous system as the
break
or the clutch this is where the body
conserves energy this is where utilizes
nutrients and and transports chemicals
to cells and metabolism goes up and and
this is a time for growth this is a time
for repair this is a time for
restoration and there's a delicate
balance between the sympathetic nervous
system and the parasympathetic nervous
system
and so then when you're feeling
a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering and you're living by
the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy
for growth repair restoration there's no
energy for long-term building projects
most people are waiting for their life
the change yeah so they can feel
gratitude to feel abundant to feel whole
you know that's the old model of cause
and effect you know so if you're living
with emptiness you're living with lack
you're living with pain most people have
been conditioned that something out
there has to take away this emptiness or
feeling inside of them but
if you believe that you're creating your
life and you're living by lack well lack
is going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now it's the scientific fact that
it's the environment that signals the
gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind so your personality
literally ad is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth so
then when you're feeling gratitude and
your heart is open you're broadcasting
energy into the field now frequency the
frequency you lay the intent of the
thought of your health or your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth it can carry the thought of
your health if you're suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know
the moment you disconnect from the
energy of your future because of some
circumstance in your life and you lose
that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where their their
mind is
they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
nitric oxide from oxytocin and then all
of a sudden your heart literally starts
to swell it literally begins to open up
and there's more energy going there and
now you're coming from a different level
of mind
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen
in a future video because
you are awesome if you want to learn to
attract great things into your life with
dr joe dispenza check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe i will see you there
the emotions that come from these energy
centers the lower energy centers in our
body do have
frequencies there's chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person